hey guys so today we're at Skywalker
Ranch and it is so incredibly beautiful
we flew into San Francisco last night
and now we're here getting a tour behind
me a little vineyard George's personal
done collection is somewhere on this
property
we've now magically transported here by
vehicle to the Lucasfilm lot so we're
going to be doing a tour here and
there's a Yoda fountain we just found
out the word goes with this very I mean
we both obviously knew that we're from
Pittsburgh like you didn't know
no did I just learn I didn't know that
you were I didn't know I was working I
thought what you didn't know you're from
the wait are you I saw Starbucks over
here we have to go to the Lucas
Starbucks do we have like special Lucas
Starbucks cups you shut up there's no
there's a place making a coffee it's
Club Java that oh we really need a Java
the hut right now and I could not be
more excited I need a shirt
I need a shirt a new shirt
they help these guys look at the
batteries when you get through the
toaster do you think maybe it wasn't
like robots they look just like this no
look it up okay
robots look just like that I was like oh
my gosh it's the robots from there so
give me a babies oh well I know what I'm
watching tonight hello everybody this is
the next day and I have come down with
some sort of a little cold now I was in
San Francisco yesterday and I went and
visited oh my god I had the best time
ever went to Skywalker Ranch went to
Industrial Light & Magic and I got to
see so much cool Star Wars stuff so now
I'm here at the pet store we just took
Maddie to get groomed and we're gonna
get him some Star Wars toys oh my gosh I
want to get him a Star Wars outfit he
also needs some Christmas things
[Music]
there's camo sock
this is what he means look at his little
leather jacket oh my goodness should we
get him a little girl outfit too
thank god that's not happening anymore
the other day I heard about what Stefani
doing the Harajuku lovers wine and guess
what it's here at Petco we have to get
him one of these days which one should
we get I think he looks super cute Oh
more Star Wars things what should I get
him ah
decisions decisions Mady got his hair
cut come here baby
Mady look at you look so fluffy oh wait
he's hot you want treat majorie treats
treats sit good boy
write it down good boy he matted down
down yes good boy this is riveting
content it is riveting content my dog is
intelligent I named it down he's doing
such a lazy down you see him yeah his
butts not even on the ground put your
bum down Peggy
oh okay you're so cute sit down the new
leather jacket whoa
can see it's beautiful come see your
outfit Medhi check this out okay here
you go oh oh
possum Oh No so I was having a real
struggle yesterday because I had this
lightsaber and I was unable to get it
through TSA but guess what
I talked them into letting you take it
through that is extra screaming they let
me have it
oh thank you
[Music]
I fences the wall not sure if you can
see it dart scratch dent I'm not a Jedi
welcome to the dark side so let's take a
peek at this and see what it's like Oh
I waited all this time to open this and
all I had to do is flip the tab